SPEAKER 1: She's
Innovation Director
at Microsoft
Research in Cambridge
and also appears on
some BBC documentaries.
[INAUDIBLE] And yeah, welcome.
HAYAN ZHANG: Hello.
Hi, everybody.
So we're so close to lunch,
so make this snappy and quick.
Hello, I'm Hayan, I'm
Director of Innovation
at Microsoft Research
in Cambridge in the UK.
The original Cambridge,
if there's any doubts.
And I call myself--
well, I'm a designer
and an engineer,
so I started out
in computer science
and I moved to being a designer.
So I worked at a
consultancy firm called
IDO for about seven years.
And in the last five
years, I've been
in Microsoft running innovation
teams, and Xbox, and research.
And I essentially call
myself a maker of things
because I think it's a
really nice fusion of design
and engineering practice,
to treat technology
as a design material and to
work with that from day one.
So I think that a quote
that really encapsulates
my philosophy about design
is from Eileen Gray, who's
a self-taught architect
and furniture designer.
She said.
"To create, one must first
question everything."
You know, this is a
really broad statement.
But to me it means
whether you're
designing an interface for an
iPhone app, or an Android app,
or a product, you're essentially
baking into that design
how you think people should go
about their day, should live,
should have a lamp
in their house,
the quality of that lamp.
I think, to me, with every
single act of design,
I think that it also
has the potential
to be an action to
change the world.
So I'm a big fan of knife
fights in the design process.
So meet me in the
dark alley, and we'll
debate over whose narrative
of the future will win.
Because I think within
design, within service design,
interaction design, we've been
talking about these narratives
that we all share-- things
like the sharing economy,
things like sustainability,
and things like open-source.
I think within our culture in
Europe and in North America,
these are sort of narratives
of a science fiction
or a designed future that we
would like to see come to pass.
But just harking back a
little bit on my childhood,
that was not always the case.
I was born in China in the
aftermath of the Cultural
Revolution.
And in my early years--
this is not a picture of me.
I did not look like a
boy when I was little.
In my early years, I went
to primary school in China.
At the time, in
the early '80s, it
was very over indexed on the
Communist Party and Party
philosophy.
So I was in a system that
was very much focused
on stripping individuals
of their personal agency,
of opinions that
differed from the Party.
It was kind of like an
institutionalized fake news
system where every
piece of information
was filtered through
this kind of philosophy.
Whether or not it
was true or not,
it had to be sort
of bent to its will.
And then transition that to
when I moved to Australia.
I moved to Australia the
year that "Star Trek--
The Next Generation"
aired on TV.
It was a revelation to me to
go from this kind of system
where individualism was frowned
upon to this world where you
might be empowered to
pursue your own interests
and to achieve what you might
be great at in the world.
I was a big fan of "Star
Trek" and particularly
enabled, empowered by
technology, where technology
would serve to enable
your personal agency
to allow you the
freedom to explore
what you were interested in.
So I sort of went into
technology as a practice
and always thinking about
sort of using technology
as this kind of design
material to change the world.
In recent years I've been
involved in a BBC documentary
series called "Big Life Fix,"
which is bringing together
seven engineers and
designers from around the UK
to invent cutting edge
technology for people in need,
which is really funny because
the audience on BBC Two,
as we're told, are kind of
like grannies in the Midlands.
So it's a real juxtaposition.
So one of the projects
that came out of the show
was around sort of supporting
a young lady called Emma.
And Emma, when she
was 28 years old,
she was diagnosed with
Parkinson's disease, which
is actually a very rare event.
And as a result of
her disease, she
had acquired an action
tremor in her hand.
Being a graphic designer
and a creative director,
she was no longer able to pursue
her job because her hand shook
when she was trying to draw
wire frames or write her name.
And so I worked with her
to think about, well,
how can we create something
that might be able to help
her overcome this symptom?
How can we fix this
problem through a design
and an engineering lens?
So I'll just quickly
show you that video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHTER]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
HAYAN ZHANG: Thanks
very much, thank you.
I mean, one of the
takeaways that I
have from doing this work, and
there are many, one of them
is that I think you
can't quite tell
if this is a design project
or an engineering project.
Because design alone
couldn't solve this problem.
But at the same time, I think--
I mean, the clip
didn't show it--
but my undertaking
was a design process.
And it was the design process
that led me to the insight
to start prototyping with
this kind of intervention.
And so an engineering
process on its own
could not achieve this either.
The other takeaway, which
I will talk about in a bit,
is just that there is so
much potential for technology
in all its forms and in
its physical form factors
to still have relevance
and make a huge impact,
that we haven't explored yet.
I know today that we've been
talking about algorithms.
We've been talking
about smart systems.
But my focus and passion, for
I guess the last 10 years,
has been about
hardware and devices.
And I think it's
through opening up
new form factors, new inputs,
new outputs, that we're
able to create a new
stage for where algorithms
can come into play
beyond mobile phones
and the desktop metaphor.
So we are with our
Microsoft Research team.
We're continuing on some of the
research into this technology.
And some of those challenges
that we are now encountering
are we really do
think that's smarter
algorithms can make the
effect more amplified.
But there's this
transitional-- there's
this question between signal
processing and machine
learning.
So where does a
signal processing end,
and where is it better to pick
up machine learning as a tool
to do this?
And we're not quite
sure without going
through the hard work of
implementing each piece
of technology to test it out.
I think through some
of the discussions
that we have around
machine learning,
there's this kind of idea
that machine learning
is the solution for everything.
I think we need to really
question that and understand
where the boundaries of
machine learning end,
and where we can best
leverage other kinds
of rule-based algorithms still.
So we're continuing to
develop some of the study apps
and tech to capture this
data for more people.
I think one of the really
interesting things that Emma
says herself, is
that she is dealing
with so much in her life and
so much from this disease.
And wearing this watch has
been able to give her back
a little bit of that
dignity that I think
the disease has taken away.
I mean, it's not a cure, and
it's not fixed everything.
But if the technology
can give her back
a little bit of her
agency and her dignity,
I think in that itself is a
really worthy value for us
to pursue.
And at the same
time, when we think
about algorithms in the
loop, or AI in the loop,
you know, by wearing
the watch, Emma
is able to regain some of
the clarity in her writing.
But it's not perfect.
This is not an
augmentation to allow
her to write like
a robot, to give
her perfectly straight lines.
There is still a little bit
of quiver in her writing,
and she enjoys that.
Because the disease
is also a fuse
with parts of her personality.
So she enjoys the imperfection.
And the technology through
not working perfectly
is actually giving her back
some of that personality
that she misses.
So let me transition
to another project
that I did recently, last year--
working with a young girl who,
when she was eight years old,
she had a car accident
with her family.
And she suffered some
traumatic brain injury.
And she is now 12.
And at the time when
she had her accident,
it was quite devastating.
She couldn't walk.
She couldn't talk.
But over time, she was
able to rehabilitate,
and now she's up and
about and running around
on the playground,
and going to school.
But she's also sustained
sort of more long term issues
with her memory.
And so I went in to see if
we could create technologies
to help her regain
some of that memory,
to help capture
some of that memory.
So through the design
process, working with her,
I was able to kind
of start to map
out what the challenges were.
Memory is kind of like--
trying to define what memory
is is kind of like sand
running through your fingers.
Everybody said she had
short-term memory loss.
But actually, she didn't have
that much short-term memory
loss.
What she did have
was this inability
to remember events or episodic
memory in the long term.
So if she'd go on a
picnic with her family,
she could remember
it for 30 minutes,
but she wouldn't be able to
remember it the next weekend.
If she took a class, she'd
be able to remember things
in the class, but she would
forget it the next time
the class came around.
So I really set about sort
of trying to think, well,
how can we create technology
that augments her memory,
augments her brain
in some ways--
not through everything, not
through everything that she's
doing, but at specific moments?
And these might be different
pieces of technology.
So thinking about how can
we build her knowledge
to complete school?
How can we help her relive
her emotional moments
with her family?
And I would say that the
results are interesting,
and they do work for her,
but at the same time,
the physical form
factors I still
find clunky because
I had to use tablets
and off-the-shelf equipment
in order to kind of augment
some of her daily routines.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
HAYAN ZHANG: I think part of
that solution, as you saw,
was some cognitive services
where we turned the teacher's
speech into text, and
she's able to rewind
that in the class to see what
happened five minutes ago.
And I think today and also
at other AI conferences,
we talk glowingly about AI and
what it's been able to achieve.
But I think when the
rubber hits the road
and we're trying to really make
solutions that work for people,
there's still a long way to go.
This technology,
I mean, I think it
was a great proof of concept,
but at the same time,
how do we capture the
voice of the teacher?
I had to put a lapel mic on
it because we couldn't isolate
her voice in the classroom.
She had a Birmingham accent.
I had to train specific
models just on her accent.
And then the kids in
the class had names
that weren't Anglo-Saxon
names, and that
was difficult to translate.
So I think there's
still a long way to go.
And also in terms
of technology form,
the fact that she has to
have this tablet next to her
in class, is not ideal.
And finally I'm just
going to quickly share
some of the work
that my team, and I
have been doing at Microsoft
Research for the last couple
of years, where we've kind
of really looked at, well,
how can we open up the space of
physical digital exploration?
How can we kind of
create new theaters,
new spaces within which people
can interact with computers
and kind of create these
new kinds of experiences?
So we've won a Best
Paper Award for CHI 2018,
so please come see us
if you're in Montreal.
And this project really
started because we were really
obsessed with expressiveness
for tangible user interfaces,
and frustrated with
the history of TUIs,
and how they were
fixed in place.
They required a lot of set up.
There was occlusion issues.
And we really wanted to
set out to create kind
of a more fluid TUI system.
And I may be old fashioned,
but I freaking love TUIs, man.
All right, so and then this is
the project that we created.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HAYAN ZHANG: So that's
the technical preview.
And we've worked with
the Microsoft HML team
to do on board, some
machine learning
in terms of detecting the
different gestures, hover
gestures.
And at the same time, we're
thinking more upstream
about what are some of
the applications that
can open up the expressiveness?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ROBOT: Don't shoot.
Bam!
I'm hit.
HAYAN ZHANG: Open up
new learning and play
opportunities.
And here we see much
more space for new kinds
of algorithms that can enrich
these play and learning
experiences.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBOT: C-- A--
R. Car.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
HAYAN ZHANG: And
so we've actually
engineered the entire
platforms from scratch,
because within the team working
in this multidisciplinary team,
we really don't see a divide
between the design vision
and the engineering
possibility of this technology.
So I work with a
multidisciplinary team
of hardware engineers
and designers,
product designers,
computer scientists,
and if you are in
Montreal, come see us.
We will be giving
hands-on demos as well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So we're running
a little bit behind,
but if there are a
couple of questions?
Otherwise, if
everybody's hungry?
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for the talk.
It was very interesting.
What interested me about
the problem solving
for Aman was there was
this step of-- like,
you had the little diagram
of how memory is divided
and then jumped to the solution.
And I was wondering if you can
maybe tell us a little bit more
how you came up with
the actual design idea
that we'll relay
speech into text
and then highlight it in colors
and also the one for the family
memories, because that was the
very interesting part about it.
HAYAN ZHANG: I think I'll
talk about family memories
because that was very
interesting to me as well.
So Aman, she can't remember
memories with her family.
And there is some research
around memory loss
and using photos to
jog someone's memory,
and in her case, it didn't work.
She could look at photos
and she wouldn't remember.
But we did a design exercise
where we went out for the day,
we had her take the photos.
And she was punting on
a boat in Cambridge,
and she thought the punter
guy was really attractive.
He looked somebody from
One Direction or something.
And so she was giggling
the entire time.
She was so delighted.
And then afterwards
we went to a cafe,
and she was sitting there.
She was look at the photos.
And when it came to the picture
she'd taken of the punter,
she didn't remember him at all.
She was like, oh, I
don't know this guy.
So she'd lost that kind of
delight from her memories.
But then while she was doing
that, her mom, sitting next
to her, just said,
oh Aman, do you
remember this is
the guy he looks
like Niall from One Direction.
And then this sort of
smile came over her face,
and suddenly she remembered
this event through her mom
retelling that story
of how she felt.
And so just, for me, through
seeing that interaction,
allowed me to kind
of create this app.
I mean, it's a very
simple app where
her family can upload
photos and record
personal memories for her.
And just through this
combination of personal stories
and images, she's able to recall
some of these memories, which
is really amazing.
AUDIENCE: And how long
does that recall last?
Like does she have to
kind of almost remember,
like create that memory
every time she looks at it,
or is there some kind of
retention of Information?
HAYAN ZHANG: I think
for me this was
a kind of short kind of
project to create something.
So there hasn't been a
more longer term study.
I think every person
is very individualized,
this kind of trauma as well.
It's challenging, because
I talked to neuroscientists
who do research into
memory, and they
talked about how
people like Aman
may never be able to
experience a memory the way
that we experience a memory.
So they may be able to
remember the details,
but they may not be able
remember the emotional quality
of the details.
I feel that through
watching her,
she is reliving some of
that emotional component.
And perhaps through
regular retrieval,
she's able to maybe build those
connections in the long term.
AUDIENCE: It's very cool.
Thank you very much.
HAYAN ZHANG: Thanks very much.
SPEAKER 1: If there
are no more questions,
then we can break for lunch.
Lunch is over there, and we will
be here at a quarter to 3:00--
2:45 sharp-- to go
on with the program.